- Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you so much for
joining us both in person
and on Zoom hybrid.
Let me start by thanking
Professor Carole McGranahan
for joining us at the
refugee seminar series
and thanking the capable
help of Teresa Delgado
for arranging this visit.
It is an like a really wonderful
honor to have Carole join.
She's been a mentor,
and she is one of the
stars of anthropology
and the refugee studies.
Professor McGranahan is
a cultural anthropologist
and historian specializing
in contemporary Tibet.
Her research focuses on issues
on colonialism and empire,
history and memory, power and politics,
refugees and citizenship,
nationalism, senses of belonging,
gender, war, and anthropology
as theoretical storytelling.
Since '94, she has conducted research
in Tibetan refugee
communities in India and Nepal
on the history and politics
of guerilla resistance
between 1950 and 1974,
which culminated in her
book, "Arrested Histories:
Tibet, the CIA, and Memories
of a Forgotten War."
It came out in 2010 with
Duke University Press.
Thinking of 20th and 21st
century Tibetan histories
and experiences as
imperial in a global sense
is a key part of her work
in relation to the CIA,
British India and the
People's Republic of China.
Professor McGranahan work
on Empire beyond Europe
can be found in an edited
volume, "Imperial Formations,"
which came out in 2007.
It was co-edited with by Anne Staler
and Peter Perdue as well,
and in "Ethnographies of U.S. Empire,"
which came out in 2018,
co-edited with John Collins.
Currently, Professor
McGranahan is completing a book
about the (indistinct).
- [Professor Carole] (indistinct).
Thank you, family,
Tibet and British India
in the first half of the 20th century
and she's finishing a decade
of research in France,
India, Nepal, New York City, Switzerland,
and Toronto titled, "Refugee Citizenship:
Asylum Refusal and Political Subjectivity
in the Tibetan Diaspora."
She's presenting from that research today,
a talk titled Refusal
as Political Practice:
an Ethnography of Citizenship
and Refugee Status.
Please help me welcome her today.
(crowd applauding)
- I'd like to say thank you to Eda Pepi
and to everyone at Yale
for inviting me to be here.
It's my pleasure to be able to
share this research with you.
So the first time I went to Toronto,
all everyone was talking
about was political asylum
and gaining convention refugee status.
But people weren't just talking about it,
they were joking about it.
There was one joke we
heard everywhere we went.
It went something like this.
"Have you heard about the Sherpa guy
who posed as a Tibetan in asylum court?
The judge asked him when the
Dalai Lama's birthday was,
and the man answered, 'Saturday?'"
Everyone who told the
joke roared with laughter
at the punchline.
Yup.
No matter how many times it
was told to Kesang and me
in this friend's apartment or that one,
Kesang would laugh so hard
she had to wipe away tears.
The joke was funny because,
of course, every Tibetan knows
that the Dalai Lama's
birthday was July 6th.
Yet in India and Nepal,
his birthday is usually not
celebrated exactly on the 6th,
but instead is celebrated on Saturday,
which is kind the national holiday.
Kind of the one day holiday
in a six-day work week.
The bida, the Chuti.
While, all Tibetans know this,
they also know that most
Sherpa's wouldn't know this
as the Sherpa community
typically does not celebrate
the Dalai Lama's birthday.
For Kesang and her friends,
the joke was humorous commentary
on Tibetan and Himalayan
immigration to North America
on a shared experience
of the asylum system
and the political possibilities
embedded in the idea of citizenship.
As an anthropologist on the alert
for a new research project,
when I heard the joke for the
fifth, sixth, seventh time,
I knew this was it.
In order to understand
why this was happening in Canada, however,
we also have to consider
the broader context,
which is Tibetan's six decades
of refusing citizenship
in South Asia,
the history behind their
immigration to United States,
and then often onto Canada,
and why the Sherpa man
was posing as a Tibetan
in the first place.
25 years ago, if you drove or walked
past the US Embassy in Kathmandu,
you would've seen a long
queue of people lined up
outside it on some days.
Many of them were Tibetan.
And as gossip went,
some of those in line were
pretending they were Tibetan.
They were young Tekkali
or Manangi or Sherpa men,
some of whom had shaved their heads,
dawned maroon robes and
pretended to be monks
based on a perceived notion
of Tibetan desirability
that they hoped would
get them a rare US visa.
One day in 1998,
Kesang and I stood in
the queue with a friend.
We calmed her nerves by talking
about the embassy official
everyone referred to as Mr. David.
Supposedly, he was a Buddhist
and he liked Tibetans.
And so if you were a Tibetan
or successfully convinced
embassy staff that you were one,
your chances of receiving a
visa were believed to be good.
Sought after in this
process was a tourist visa,
which one would enter the United States
and stay beyond its expiration
with the intention of somehow, some way
securing a job in the USA
so that you could send
money home to your family.
After several hours of
waiting outside the embassy,
our friend emerged victorious.
She had received a visa.
Although none of us knew it
back in that day on 1998,
almost 20 years later,
both she and Kesang would
be living in Toronto
as Canadian citizens.
In this span of time,
a major ship shift happened in
the Tibetan refugee community
with thousands of individuals
migrating from South
Asia to North America.
That first visit that I made to Toronto
wasn't only about jokes,
there was also serious reflection.
All I have are stories, a book of stories.
Pepe said this to me
as we sat in the Shangri-La
Tibetan Restaurant in Toronto
on a snowy December night in 2007.
I had asked about her
generation's experiences
of immigrating from South
Asia to North America.
Although she was now a 20-year-old woman,
we had known each other
since she was a six-year-old
girl in Kathmandu.
And I was a young graduate student
just beginning my research
with the Tibetan refugee community.
She and her mother had
just moved to Canada,
and I was visiting them
there for the first time.
Again, this is in 2007.
Our belly is full of shabdak,
tingmo, and aloo phingsha.
We left the restaurant and
walked back to her apartment
where her mother, Kesang,
was waiting for us.
We greeted her and settled
in around the table.
Pepe turned back to our
earlier conversation.
The issues we are facing
are papers, money,
and rights, she said.
Citizenship papers, money for everything,
and the right to protest.
Kesang joined and saying,
"We didn't have any of those in Nepal."
Tibetans didn't have papers,
money, or rights there.
She, referring to Pepe, was born in Nepal
but couldn't be a citizen.
Pepe was not alone in this.
For six decades, Tibetan
refugees have lived in South Asia
without citizenship.
Tibetans refused citizenship in South Asia
to both claim sovereignty in Tibet
and to assert political
equality and interdependence,
vis-a-vis the governments
of India and Nepal.
As Tibetans like Pepe and
Kesang moved to North America,
their refusal as political
practice changes in some ways,
though remains the same in others.
For people who have been
collectively dispossessed,
what does it mean to refuse
international norms of citizenship
by insisting on a sovereignty
that has been lost?
In the case of Tibet,
refusing citizenship in South Asia
is a means of claiming past, present,
and future state sovereignty.
Tibet was, Tibet is, Tibet will be.
This claim challenges
globally hegemonic formulas
for sovereignty and citizenship.
It rejects the idea
that the state of Tibet
is merely a former political entity,
and instead asserts contemporary
political legitimacy.
Yet what happens to political
claims embedded in refusal
when refugees become citizens elsewhere?
How might refusal be reconfigured
to maintain political claims
to home and state sovereignty?
The seeming contradiction
of Tibetan refugees
accepting citizenship in North America
after decades of refusing it in South Asia
demonstrates that hegemonic
categories and practices
need not be debilitating or total.
Tibetans collective refusal
of an externally assigned political status
posits a different status in its place.
In so doing, it refuses the probable
in favor of the possible.
So in this paper,
I argue that the unfolding history
of the Tibetan refugee citizenship,
documentation, and migration
challenges contemporary norms
and possibilities for political status.
Tibetans in exile do so first
by inhabiting to ostensibly
oppose categories
that of refugee and citizen,
and they do so second
by refusing to accept their
sovereignty as past tense.
That is.
Their current status,
regardless of whether it
is refugee or undocumented
or stateless or citizen,
rests in a temporality
guided as much by a Buddhist
sense of impermanence
as by an irreverence
for international norms.
Strategies might change,
but the goal remains the same,
regaining Tibetan sovereignty in Tibet.
So I also want to argue that
ethnographic knowledge is vital
for understanding experiences of refugees.
That is alongside political, historic,
or legal knowledge, for example.
Ethnography provides us with a unique
and complimentary way of knowing.
Specifically, ethnographic research
gives us conceptual
insights to life as lived,
to how structures feel,
to how categories are experienced,
and importantly, into worlds
of both action and agency,
which for so long have
been denied to refugees.
My research with the Tibetan community
spans over three decades
and involves personal and
political commitments,
as well as the relationships
and ethnographies that are...
Sorry, relationships and obligations
that are at the heart of ethnography.
Kesang and I first met in 1994.
You can see us here.
This is outside of the
airport in Kathmandu.
She and I have been close ever since,
sharing joys and sorrows
over three decades
in three separate countries,
including just a few weeks ago.
You can see the photo
here about a decade ago.
We're at Niagara Falls.
And then this photo which was
taken in October of this year.
My second argument is about refusal
as 21st century intervention
into possibilities for
citizenship and sovereignty.
By this, I do not mean the
refusal of immigration judges
or officials who denied passage,
denied recognition,
asylum, status to people.
Instead, I mean refusal as a willful,
conscious political act.
To refuse can be generative and strategic,
a deliberate move toward one thing,
belief, practice, or community,
and away from another.
The generative aspect of
refusal recognizes the sociality
of saying no in order to
build something different.
This affiliative aspect
is one of the things
that links refusal to resistance,
but refusal is not a
synonym for resistance,
where resistance involves
consciously defying
or opposing superiors
in a context of differential
power relationships
between state and society,
refusal rejects such a hierarchy,
also rejects subjugation
as the position from
which action is taken.
Instead, refusal reposits
relationships as between equals,
insisting inequity rather than inequity.
And so here in referring to refusal,
I draw on the important research
of anthropologists, Audra Simpson,
for whom refusal is both
ethnographic and political,
both stance and theory.
Simpson is one of the
scholars in indigenous studies
leading the way and theorizing refusal.
I think you're also,
of the work of scholars such as Eve Tuck
and Wayne Yang, Kim Talbert.
However, around the same time,
we also see refusal being
theorized in other fields.
We see it in black studies,
and especially in black feminist studies
with scholars such as Tina Campt,
Gina Athena Ulysse, Savannah Shange
We see it in pre pandemic
research on vaccine refusal.
And, of course, we see
it in current research
about the pandemic,
as well as in contemporary
populous politics
such as the January 6th insurrection.
We see it in work with
conscientious objectors.
We see it in research with refugees
who reject the norms of the
international refugee regime.
And this last one is the Tibetan stance,
a position enacted in a very specific
and unusual political context.
In order to understand what is happening
with Tibetan immigration in North America,
it's important to understand the history
of the Tibetan refugee
community in South Asia.
So in 1949, Mao Zedong's
People Liberation Army
marched into Tibet.
By 1951, had taken over the country.
In the mid-1950s,
Tibetans began to fight
back in eastern Tibet.
By 1959, the fighting reached
Lhasa, Tibet's capital.
The Dalai Lama, Tibet's
political and religious leader
escaped into exile in India
and thousands of Tibetans followed him.
Once in India, the Dalai Lama's government
immediately reconstituted itself.
It retains today the
uncontested leadership
of the Tibetan community.
The Tibetan government in exile
is a functioning government.
It has an elected parliament,
it has a court system,
it conducts a census, it collects taxes,
it runs its own school,
it maintains hegemonic
practices of belonging,
and it is the sole representative
of over 140,000 Tibetans
resident in India and Nepal,
as well as elsewhere around the world.
Although citizenship has been debated
at different times in exile history,
it was in the early 1960s,
again, in the 1970s,
and most recently in the last decade
that exile government has
long refused citizenship
in South Asia as part of its
political claim to Tibet.
However, this refusal is complicated.
No country in South Asia,
not India, not Nepal,
not any other South Asian state
are signatories to the 1951 UN Convention
relating to the status of refugees
or to the 1967 Protocol
which updated the convention.
What is thus typical of many countries
is not the norm in South Asia.
Applying for and receiving
UN designated convention refugee status
sets in motion a series
of rights and protections
guaranteed by the state,
including a path to citizenship
rather than a return to a country
where one would face political threats.
In South Asia, Tibetans are refugees
without the opportunity
to apply for convention refugee status,
whether they are born in
Tibet, in India, or in Nepal.
As a result, six decades of families,
multiple generations live in
South Asia as undocumented
or underdocumented peoples.
There is no path to citizenship for them,
and this is unusual in the world.
One tension of exile sovereignty
is that individuals lack identification
and life event documents.
Tibetans in South Asia
hold either fake documents
or locally issued old fashioned ones
not widely recognized
outside of South Asia,
or they have no documents at all.
In India, most but not all Tibetans
hold renewable Foreigner's
Registration Certificates,
referred to as RCs,
and identification certificates
referred to as ICs.
In Nepal, the situation is worse
as the government has never
had an official program
to identify and provide documentation
to all Tibetan refugees.
Although at various points up until 1989,
it did issue some
documents to some Tibetans.
The United Nations High Commission
for Refugees Office in Kathmandu
assists as a transit facility
for Tibetans who have escaped from Tibet
and are traveling on to India.
So unlike in Palestine,
the United Nations does
not offer any identity
or travel documentation to Tibetans
or have any Tibet-specific
offices in India or Nepal.
The only document available
to all Tibetan refugees
is the Green Book issued
by the exile government,
and that is what you can
see on the screen now.
These are the green books.
They are shaped like passports,
but they cannot be used like one.
The history of possibilities
for Tibetan citizenship
in South Asia is unclear.
According to the citizenship
laws of both India and Nepal,
many Tibetans should qualify
for citizenship in each country,
either through birth
or through an established
connection to the country.
At several times in exile history,
vigorous discussions have taken place
as to whether or not Tibetans
should seek citizenship.
Each time the government has refused,
but tensions surround what's
perceived to be a differential
application of this refusal.
As one man in India said to me,
the Sikyong, who is the president
of the Tibetan government,
and all the government ministers
have citizenship and the
benefits that come with it.
"Our country is Tibet,
we are all fighting for it,
but it is the ordinary
Tibetans in India and Nepal
who make the sacrifice of
not having citizenship,"
end quote.
In India, a handful of Tibetans
have begun to make claims to citizenship
as provided in the
Citizenship Act of India.
These claims are
controversial among Tibetans
as well as among Indian
government officials.
The high courts have approved
citizenship for Tibetans
only to have government offices
not recognize the court decisions
in order to prolong applicant's
imperial foreigner status.
So, again, that foreigner status
is something that dates back
to the time of British India.
Such claims are not possible in Nepal
where Tibetans have no name status
and where Chinese political influence
has increased greatly since the 1990s.
The most recent change in India
is the Tibet Rehabilitation
Policy of 2014.
In this policy, the government of India
claimed the right to
terminate Tibetan's leases
and other government grants stating,
here's direct quote,
"The Tibetans in India
are considered refugees
and they are staying temporarily in India
on humanitarian grounds," end quote.
The conservative exile government
publicly claims neutrality
on citizenship for Tibetans in India,
stating it is a personal
decision for people to make.
Privately, however, everyone knows
you are not supposed to
apply for citizenship.
Privately, people know that
to do so could cause problems.
What happens therefore when
Tibetans leave South Asia?
What does refusal look like in countries
where undocumented status is
neither allowed nor advised?
What options do communities have
when convention refugee
status is not a possibility?
Section 134 of the US
Immigration Act of 1990
authorized the one time
immigration of 1,000,
in quotes, "displaced
Tibetans to the USA."
They were chosen by lottery,
and their families allowed
to join them in the US
after five years had passed.
This first group of Tibetan immigrants
paved the way for additional groups
whose imagination was
triggered by the first.
Following this official migration program,
in the late 1990s,
large number numbers
of individual Tibetans
began to migrate to North
America on tourist visas,
most flew into and
stayed in New York City,
especially in Queens.
And here you see a piece of art
by the artist, Sodhon, from 2014.
Unlike the first official group, however,
the later second and
third unofficial groups
had nothing waiting for them
except for Tibetan friends
and family members.
Without citizenship and working papers,
they found only certain
jobs were available,
and over time realized
they needed citizenship.
However, how do you acquire
citizenship in a new country?
Each country's rules
on this are different.
In the United States, one way
you might gain citizenship
is via political asylum.
The US government declares
five groups of people
eligible for asylum.
Those who have suffered persecution
or feel they will suffer
persecution due to race,
religion, nationality,
membership in a particular social group
or political opinion.
Not all Tibetans meet
those qualifications,
so not all qualify for
political asylum in the USA.
Instead, they formed a new type
of citizenship migration to Canada.
They have made a path from
New York City to Toronto
via Buffalo and Niagara Falls.
"Go to Buffalo," everyone says.
"You have to go to Buffalo."
In 2005, Kesang phoned me
in Colorado one morning
from New England.
"I need help," she said.
"I need to go to Buffalo."
She knew I had a good friend in Toronto
who had made his way there via Buffalo.
"Can you call him and get the
information?" she asked me.
I did, and he gave me
detailed instructions.
And I'm gonna read them
now to you verbatim.
"Take the Greyhound bus from
New York City," he said.
"At the bus station in Buffalo,
get a taxi to Vive La Casa.
The taxi drivers all know this place.
It should be $10 for the fair.
This is a missionary shelter
where she will be taken
care of by volunteers
who will help her fill
out the asylum forms."
"Does she speak English?" he asked me.
"No," I said.
"Then tell her to go with a friend.
Bring her Green Book,
her (indistinct) book
and Nepali passport."
The story is that she,
"I thought the passport
that she's not really a Nepali citizen."
"It's true," he said, "but
it's still hard to explain."
Tibetans go to Buffalo to go to Canada.
But why Canada?
Why are Tibetans going to Canada
rather than staying in the US?
The answer is simple.
In Canada, assessments for
asylum are reckoned differently,
with tribunals determining or not
whether Tibetans qualify for
convention refugee status,
not for political asylum.
Overall, Tibetans have
been deemed eligible.
One thus appears before
a judge or tribunal
with the need to convince them
that you are indeed a bonafide Tibetan.
All true or bonafide Tibetans
immediately qualify for
citizenship in Canada
as well as for employment assistance,
English language courses,
free healthcare, and more.
And, of course, any bonafide Tibetan
would know the exact date of
the Dalai Lama's birthday.
In the 1980s, a group of Catholic nuns
formed a rest house for refugees
fleeing war in Central
America, from Guatemala,
from El Salvador, from Honduras.
At the rest house, they
provided shelter, meals,
and clothing for the refugees,
but that was not all.
They also provided free legal assistance
in preparing one's asylum
application for Canada,
submitted all the necessary papers
and information to the
Canadian government,
and then drove refugees
directly to the US-Canada border
once all of their documents were in place.
The nuns named this
rest house Vive La Casa.
On the day I arrived at Vive La Casa,
my first meeting was with the director.
He and I spoke for a
while about my research,
then he said, "Let's go see
how many Tibetans are here today."
He explained there were
118 beds at Vive La Casa,
and all were usually full.
"Normally" he said,
"anywhere from one to 10 of those beds
are occupied by Tibetans."
"I've worked here for four years.
We've had dozens of Tibertans.
They are the nicest people," end quote.
We went to see the assistant director
to whom he introduced me,
and then he asked her,
"Who are our Tibetans this week?"
She paused a second,
and then in surprise said,
"There are no Tibetans here right now.
One man just left for Canada this morning.
He was alone,
and now there are no Tibetans
in the house," end quote.
Together, they marveled at this fact
that there were no Tibetans
at Vive La Casa that morning.
And they reassured me that, in quotes,
"In recent memory,
there hasn't been a time
when there were no Tibetans at Vive."
So you can see here is one of
the rooms where people stay
while they are waiting for
their papers to be processed.
Here, you have a room for children
and you can see kids as well as volunteer.
Lots of very bright and
fun things to do here.
And here's something that was
mentioned to me numerous times
by people I spoke with in Toronto.
The murals at Vive and
the importance of flags.
And you can see down at the
very bottom of the E there,
in the corner of the
E, is the Tibetan flag.
All the staff members
had stories of Tibetans
who had stayed there.
And almost every Tibetan in Toronto
had a story of staying at Vive.
They remembered particular staff members
or cooking food or painting murals
or picking out clothes
in the donation room
before departing for Canada.
They remembered also
the other refugees there
from around the world.
Vive La Casa director, Peter Merle,
showed me the registration books
for a four-day period that month.
In this period, mostly individuals,
but sometimes whole families
had arrived from Bangladesh,
Colombia, Congo, El Salvador,
Guatemala, Haiti, Honduras,
Nicaragua, Pakistan, Peru, Sri
Lanka, Trinidad and Tobago,
Zimbabwe and Tibet.
"There's a constant stream of
people coming in," said Peter.
"And usually five to 12 people
going to Canada each day."
"I say goodbye to them on
the morning they depart,
and I say, 'I hope I
never see you again.'"
In other words, may your asylum
application be successful.
But once at the border,
how does one prove that
you are actually Tibetan,
and what does it mean to be Tibetan?
Per the Canadian government,
it means one is a Tibetan refugee
associated with the Dalai Lama
and the central Tibetan
administration in exile.
It mean one possesses a
Green Book, speaks Tibetan,
and can narrate or otherwise perform
a convincing Tibetan identity.
Tibetans have their own ideas
about what will best
display their Tibetansness
and, of course, their ideas
do not always converge
with those held by Canadian
attorneys and tribunals.
"Speak Tibetan and wear
a chuba for God's sake,"
one attorney told me he
advised Tibetan clients.
And a chuba, as you can see here,
is a form of Tibetan dress.
You see here two elderly women in Toronto.
This is in Parkdale, the
Tibetan neighborhood.
The striped aprons they
have over their chuba
signified that they're married women,
but form of national dress
immediately recognizable.
However, not just for the elderly.
And here you can see,
this is at the weekly Wednesday
gorshey in Toronto.
Every single person
dancing in this photograph
is wearing a chuba.
So you can see anyone who
has that striped apron over
signifying married woman.
The rest would be unmarried women.
However, this is also a
gender neutral form of dress.
So here, more specifically,
you can see some men
also wearing the chuba.
And a couple people, some have
it up over their shoulders,
some have it folded it down.
Again, national dress throughout Tibet.
Many Tibetans who speak
English well use a translator
when they go before the judge.
Some have told me of the experience
of the Tibetan English translator
not being as fluent in
English as they are.
They listen to their well
crafted answers in Tibetan
be translated into a broken English.
Nuances lost, details omitted,
their deep answers rendered
shallow by the translator.
Tibetans who do not speak English,
tell different stories both
of anxiety and anticipation.
A shared concern all have
is with what sort of stories
one is supposed to tell the judge.
As a young woman
explained to me in Queens,
"We don't want to lie,
but feel compelled to."
"This is not," she insisted
"because Tibetans are dishonest,
but because they're told
they need to embellish their stories."
Her husband added,
"Maybe they don't really need to do that,
but they hear that they do."
The belief that asylum seekers
lie circulates globally,
making refugees banal figures of distrust.
In New York City,
Tibetans have been placed
on the list of refugees
who have known stories.
in The New Yorker, author, Suketu Mehta,
quotes an immigration
attorney who explains to him,
direct quote, "The immigration
people know all the stories.
There's one for each country.
There's the Colombia rape story.
They all say they were raped by FARC.
There's the Rwanda rape story,
the Tibetan refugee story.
The details for each are
the same," end quote.
In Toronto, one attorney implied to me
that Tibetan stories
are often seen as tame
in comparison to those of others.
Direct quote, "Some tribunal
members hate Tibetan cases
because they come in after Rwandan guy
with one arm," end quote.
How can Tibetan suffering compete
and how does one operate in a system
that allows suffering to be competitive,
or that disqualifies individuals
because of consonants
in their experiences?
Many Tibetans do tell the
truth in asylum court.
Numerous individuals shared with me
that they told their actual story
against other advice they received,
or that they spoke English
rather than Tibetan.
As one attorney in Toronto told me,
"Tibetans don't need to
lie here," end quote.
Kesang's story didn't surprise me at all.
Her strategy was to answer
the judge's questions
as honestly as possible.
She says, "I told him I
threw my fake Nepali passport
into the river.
I wanted to get rid of
it as fast as possible.
Then he asked me about Tibetan culture,
and I told him I was in a dance
troupe when I was younger.
I did one of the dances for
him right in the courtroom.
Oh, I told him everything, and I danced.
We were laughing and he
approved my refugee status."
So the photo you now see
is of a dance troupe that
Kesang was in back in Kathmandu.
She is third one from the
left wearing the green chuba
with a purple shirt underneath.
So in the end, there is no punchline
to the joke about the Sherpa man
and the Dalai Lama's birthday.
Although that story was from Toronto,
similar stories circulate in New York City
and throughout the Tibetan diaspora.
The story about the US
embassy official in New Delhi
who asked the non Tibetan posing as a monk
to take off his monk's
robes and retie them.
And, of course, as everyone
listening to this story knew,
the man couldn't do it.
The story about the asylum officer
who never asks about actual
political persecution
but asks instead if the petitioner knows
what the four noble truths are,
"As if this was Toronto
rather than New York City,"
says a Tibetan man in Queens.
And the tale about the asylum
officer who always says no.
Who says, "There is no Tibet.
Tibet is a part of China,"
and who never grants asylum
no matter how gruesome,
how devastating, or how true one story is.
Our research needs to
recognize the conditions
and meet the needs of the
current political moment.
This is so for our research topics,
our methods, our theories.
Quantitative research and
also qualitative research
needs to be paired with
ethnography and vice versa.
Together, we can see both big picture
and finer grain detail, large
structures and histories,
as well as the lived everyday experience,
kind of both wide angled
and zoomed in views.
Ethnography is not just
another qualitative method.
It is more than that.
It is also a epistemology.
And in that, it is theory.
One theory grown from
ethnographic seeds is refusal.
Refusal is insistence on the
possible over the probable.
And here I think of
Isabelle Stinger's insight
that if we follow
probability, there is no hope,
just a calculated authorization...
Sorry, a calculated anticipation
authorized by the world as it is.
Hope combines with will to refuse
such authorized anticipations,
thus moving away from the
probable into the possible.
This does not happen only in courtrooms
or immigration lines, but
also in everyday life.
It is about joking in friendship,
about recalibrating new experiences
to find affordances and attunements
to longstanding ways of being,
of knowing, of interacting.
It is as likely to take place on sidewalks
and in apartments as
an attorney's offices.
Refusal is a form of hope.
And Canada, over the last 15 years,
I have again and again experienced this
as the remaking of Canadian
places as Tibetan places,
and vice versa.
And so in conclusion,
I want to take you to an
iconic Canadian landmark.
So here we are in Tim Hortons.
One summer day, Kesang
and I went to Tim Hortons,
the ubiquitous Canadian donut
and coffee shop in Jameson.
She said she wanted coffee.
"There's better coffee
down the street," I said,
thinking of CapitalEspresso
down near Parkdale
Community Legal Services.
A building I knew well,
where some of the attorneys
with whom I work on asylum
and family reunification bases were based
and where signs and pamphlets
were printed in numerous languages
and put up on the wall
and available on counters,
including in the Tibetan language.
A lifelong tea drinker,
Kesang, said back to me,
"I don't really care about the coffee,
I want to see who is there."
Continuing, she said, "Tim
Hortons is like Kora at Boudha,
I see everyone I know there."
For Tibetans who live
near the Boudha chorten,
pictured here in Kathmandu,
doing Kora or circumambulation,
a form of walking meditation,
around the chorten in
the morning or afternoon,
or sometimes both, is a social activity
as much as a religious activity.
It is a main part of the day for people.
Kesang laughed as she said this, saying,
"There is nowhere to do Kora in Jameson."
Instead she said,
"People go to Tim Hortons
to see who is already there,
and to hope that someone
you know will come out
as you are going in."
The following spring,
I was in Jameson again
and stopped by the Tim Hortons on my own.
Two older men were coming out,
two young Tibetan women were going in.
They saw a friend approaching
and they called out to her,
ja btungs kha shog,
come and drink tea.
So come and drink tea.
This is the practice
of refugee citizenship.
This is refusal as
possibility still unfolding
in this world.
Thank you.
So maybe we can start with
questions from the audience.
- [Attendee] Who's inspired you
to start working with
the Tibetan community,
(indistinct) in South Asia or in general?
- I get asked that question a lot.
Thank you for that.
So when I was in college,
I wanted to study abroad.
And I had never left the
United States before.
And I learned of a study
abroad program to Nepal.
And I remember the...
The first line said, "Nepal
is a country of superlatives."
And it went on to talk about the country
as this, you know,
from sea level to the
top of Mount Everest,
Hinduism, Buddhism, 40
different languages spoken
in a country the size
of Tennessee, basically.
And I was captivated and
decided to go there, and did.
And in the very first weeks
of the program, they took us,
so we were a group of maybe
20 US college students,
up to a village close to
the border with Tibet.
So for anyone who's familiar with Nepal,
we were in Marpha, which
is just south of Jomsom,
which is just south of Mustang.
And we lived there with families
and studied the Nepali language.
So we stayed there for two weeks,
right below, kind of 10 minute walk
from the village of Marpha
was a Tibetan refugee camp.
And this was on a trekking route,
and the way you trucking Nepal
is where you go hiking
from village to village
and stay with families
each night and guest house.
Well, back in the day.
Now, you might just
stay in a little hotel.
And you never spent really
more than one night in a place,
and traveling usually in small groups.
So because we were staying and
we were a group of students
learning to speak Nepali, we
became a tourist attraction.
So people would come
to see this strange group
of American students
who were living in the village
and learning to speak Nepali.
And what the Tibetan
men and women told me,
and they would come each day
to hang out in the afternoon,
drink tea, and just chat,
changed the whole course of my life.
So again, I was 20 years old at the time,
and they told me they
had lost their country,
and that they couldn't go back.
At the time, there was no
way to make a phone call
or to send a letter to Tibet,
so the men and women I was talking to
said we left behind our parents
and our brothers and sisters
and friends and grandparents,
and this had been 30
years since they had left.
They had no communication
at all with their family.
And that alone blew my mind, right?
At the time, there was one place
you could make a phone call in Kathmandu,
but I could go there and pay money
and call my parents if I wanted to.
So that was important, but
it had never occurred to me
you could lose your country.
And for anyone in this room
who works in the field of refugee studies,
that is often the position that
most refugees are in, right?
It also hadn't occurred
to them necessarily
like at that initial moment
that they were going to become refugees.
Or even that after the
initial becoming a refugee,
that they weren't going to
be going back to a renewed
and safe landscape in
just a matter of months.
And so I wanted to know,
well, what happened and why
and why don't I know about this?
And so that was the start of me
trying to learn what had happened,
to educate myself, and to
share that story with others.
And here I am 30 years later.
Tibetans now can make phone calls
and can maybe send some packages.
Everything is heavily
surveilled though and censored,
so you have to be very careful.
But there is at least
communication now between families.
But for the first three
decades, there was none at all.
And imagine living with that, right?
What would it be like to
live your life like that
not knowing the fate of your family,
not being able to just check in?
I mean, think of how connected
we are with cell phones now
and how many times...
Think of the people you you connect
with every single day through your phone
or some sort of digital form of technology
even if you don't see them face to face.
What would it be like to live without that
and without knowing?
So that's how I got started.
It made a big impression on me.
- [Attendee] Thank you so much.
I have a little bit more specific question
in the case of India
and what you were saying
about like resident,
or residence, and how that sort of process
of applying for that works,
and like who gets that?
And also have you encountered people
who have obtained Indian citizenship?
- So, yes.
And as that one man said,
that Tibetan government officials had it
because they had to be able
to travel internationally.
And some of them I think also appreciated
the perks that came with it, right?
Like, the rights that you do have.
If you have a passport,
or in this country,
write a driver's license,
those markers, those documents
of citizenship rights
come with it.
If you are stateless
with no documentation,
you literally have zero rights, right?
Convention refugee status
gives you some rights,
again, but not available
to Tibetans in India.
So an RC or an IC
registration certificates.
And I say, I mean, I can
give you the details later.
There are specific thresholds like,
if you or your parents came
here before a certain date,
so there's certain things like
that that you have to go by.
So many Tibetans, but not
all do have these in India.
Foreigner's Registration Certificates
require renewing annually.
So you have to go.
It often requires also paying
bribes to get that work done.
Or traveling to wherever
the nearest office is
that is going to renew this for you.
So in Nepal, it's not that way.
In India, there are
forms of documentation.
These are not necessarily
recognized outside of India.
So the Indian government will
issue a travel kind of visa,
or a travel stamp on your
identity certificate.
And actually in the longer
version of this talk,
I think maybe I cut too much.
Seems like we have a lot of time left.
I talk about a Tibetan woman in Toronto
who traveled to Europe
on this Indian issued,
government issued identities, IC,
identity certificate that
had a stamp on it saying
she could travel internationally.
And she said she landed in Europe,
and the immigration officials
like made fun of her.
We're like calling people
over to like, "Look at this."
And she just felt this sense of shame.
And so some of the
conversations I've had with her
are about how she wants to
impart secure citizenship
and a sense of security
and safety for her children
so that they don't go through
what it is she's gone through.
But the difference
kind of just to fully pull
in the idea of refusal
than between, say, her experience in India
and her experience now in Canada, right?
Where she has received
citizenship, not refused it, right?
So refusing citizenship
for Tibetans in India
has allowed them for a very long time now,
or it's been 63 years,
to argue that they are
not accepting citizenship
in India or Nepal because
they are citizens of Tibet.
It's just Tibet is colonized
right now by China, right?
So they can't activate to
realize that citizenship
in that way, but it's kind
of this deferral, right?
So you might say,
"Okay, well then if you take citizenship
in the USA or Canada or
France or Switzerland
or all these other countries
that don't allow you to live
in an undocumented status
for multiple generations,
how does that impact your claim to Tibet?
And so the argument that is made
is that it enables us to
fight for that claim, right?
It enables us to fight for
that Tibetan citizenship.
So in essence,
it's a form of dual
citizenship as I understand it.
The acquiring of Canadian citizenship
or of American citizenship
is not the loss or denial
or forfeiture of Tibetan citizenship,
but it's now a dual sort of thing.
Like, now with the backing
of not just a US or Canadian passport,
but also that security, right?
And the lack of shame, the lack of stigma,
the ability to act in a new way.
And so that's why that line about,
it's kind of the goal is the same,
like, the argument shifts, right?
So when refusal has that malleability
in terms of what are the
political needs of the moment
and why is it perhaps this is arising now.
- [Attendee] I an avid reader of yours.
It's such a privilege and
delight to hear your person.
So thanks so much for making this happen.
I actually wanted to...
I have two sort of questions about refusal
as both a concept and as a practice.
And I really appreciate building on
and sort of also taking
diverse directions,
existing families, fellowship on refusal.
So I wanted to...
If you could speak to one,
which is, as ethnographer yourself,
what is your entry point into refusal
in your own position as a ethnographer
who's sustained these relationships,
maintain them, committed to
them for so many years now?
So are you approaching that
mentality from the perspective
(speaker drowns out by another speaker)
who are doing this kind of refusal work?
Are you also, as an ethnographer,
participating in it, against
it, within, despite it?
So that's one question I
would like you to answer.
And secondly, within these
communities of exile or refugee
(indistinct) in places outside Tibet.
Other sort of conflicts
about that refusal,
whether it is gendered or
about positions of class,
like, within the communities itself,
what are the kinds of
contestations about refusal
if they're acknowledging
it as sort of one practice?
Yeah, those two things.
- So starting with the first.
Let's go in order.
So back to refusal as a
stance, as well as a theory,
and not everyone might be
fully familiar with the work,
so this is really drawing
on the work of Audra Simpson
who I mentioned, for
whom ethnographic refusal
is not just the study of refusal
as a political practice by a community,
but also an option of the scholar
to not disclose certain
ethnographic details
or stories or even arguments, right?
That those must be held.
And she posits this as not
just the sort of decisions
we all have to make as authors.
In writing, you can't put everything in,
so you choose to leave some stuff out.
This is not that.
This is, again, a willful
conscious decision
to leave out things that a
reader would expect, right?
That scholarship would demand,
that people expect to know
based on the research you did,
that you say, "I'm not going to tell you."
I'm not going to give you the
information that ethnography
or whatever your field is,
political science, history, sociology,
has historically demanded
to know based on research.
So that just to share with folks
who aren't familiar with Audra's work.
For me, historically, I
have worked with refusal
as a practice of the community
because that's where I
first encountered it.
And originally I wasn't
doing research on this.
It was just kept coming
up again and again.
Even before I started
the research on asylum,
I was so struck by the way
that people I interacted with
consistently used the word, we refused it.
That was the term they use
when they were talking about citizenship.
And speaking in the collective,
not speaking individually.
So I came to it that way,
and that was initially
the way that I used it.
Familiar with Audra's work,
familiar with the idea of
refusal as ethnographic stands,
but, for me, that has
only come very recently,
and I'll just quickly share the story
of how I've used ethnographic
refusal in my research
'cause I do think it's relevant.
And that is in...
Just in this last year.
So one year ago, actually
it was November, 2021,
I gave a lecture at the AAA's in Baltimore
in which I told the
story of a woman, right?
It was kind of the ethnographic
biography of one person.
And someone who had been
a difficult personality,
who had lived a difficult
and a very sad life.
And I told her story.
Maybe a couple things left out,
not necessarily for ethnographic refusal,
more for respective for care.
And I had told her story,
she had recently passed away,
in conjunction with her family.
So her family knew I was telling her story
and had worked with me on...
They hadn't read it 'cause
they didn't want to,
but they knew I was doing this.
Afterwards, as I was preparing
this lecture for publication
and was finalizing it,
and you might know just how
long this all takes, right?
Like, to come up with a long research talk
to convert it to an article.
I stumbled across a photo of this woman
that I had forgotten about
and I sent it to someone
in her family, like,
"Oh, look, I just found this
old photo of so and so."
And that person...
Something in that photo
triggered something in her
and she wrote back to me,
and then we talked and she said,
"I don't want the story to
be out in the world anymore,"
and, "Can you please not write it?"
And I wrote back immediately said,
"I will not tell the..."
I mean, I can tell the story
of not telling the story, right?
But I said, "If you don't
want me to tell the story,
I won't, and I'm not going to,
and I probably will make
that promise to you."
And I had already presented it publicly,
it was already up online as a video.
Lots of people had watched it,
lots of people had been in the audience.
And I contacted...
It was AES.
So AES had had put it up.
It was the distinguished lecture for AES.
The video was up and I said,
"I need you to take down the video."
And the article was due in like two days.
And I wrote to the editors
of the journal and I said,
"I'm really sorry.
I was going to be ready to send it to you,
but I can't send this to you now
and I need to take some
time to rethink this."
I was scheduled to give a
talk on it in California.
I had to contact those people, and I said,
"I can't come present this talk,
and I need to regroup
and see if I have anything
to present to you."
I took a week to just kind of ponder,
ponder and think about what to do.
And I ended up coming up
with a plan how I could...
What happens is that her story
was the heart of the talk I had given.
And I had to go deep into my notes,
like, into my field
notes going back decades,
as well as into my relationships myself.
And I did find stories to tell.
And so the article now exists.
If you can go and read it,
it came out in August in AE.
And the article is
called Theory as Ethics,
is this particular article.
It was about this,
theory from ethnography.
It was about relationships being
at the heart of what we do,
and what does it mean to not tell a story
that the discipline
would expect me to tell.
And actually...
So when I did go to
California and I presented it
to an interdisciplinary audience,
and I kind of shared
like as I'm doing now,
afterwards, I had someone tell me,
"You could have told the
story anyways of that woman."
Just not getting it,
not understanding the
ethics of what it means
to refuse to tell something
that's been trusted to you
because it would cause pain in the world,
because someone else
doesn't need to know, right?
What is our right to know?
So, second question, refresh my memory,
and then I'll...
Sorry, that was a long answer.
You didn't know what you
were asking when you-
(attendee faintly speaking)
- [Attendee] The second
was about contestations
within the community on refusal.
- Oh, very few.
The Tibetan community
is incredibly united.
There's not so much
contestation as there is,
frankly, jealousy.
So folks inside India,
especially in India,
hold tight to the not gaining citizenship.
Nepal again was never an issue.
So it's not like you could have opinion
one way or the other,
whereas in India, there is
an active conversation on it.
It's more...
Now, there's a wistfulness.
Oh, look at those two buttons
in X country who have it.
And then you have folks
perhaps in Sunnyside
or Long Island City saying,
Oh, back in India we had the following,
and there's wistfulness and nostalgia
over sense of community
and things that were
positive about that, right?
So there's ways, again,
there's refusals in wanting
to cross certain lines, right?
But that is very much a discourse
within the Tibetan community.
What does it mean to be united?
What does it mean to have an
active political struggle?
And the community is
incredibly united on that.
You had your hand up as well.
- [Attendee] Yes, thank you.
Very fascinating talk.
Thank you.
Two quick questions also.
So one is about roots.
I'm interested in...
I can see that Vive La
Casa is a very central note
in this move from America to Canada,
but are they also moving into Canada
straight from South Asia,
or does it have to go-
- No, they all come in
through the United States.
- [Attendee] Right, right.
And why is that the case?
- Because this is individual immigration.
So unless...
So recently, there was
a citizen organized,
Canadian government
approved immigration plan
to bring over a group of Tibetans
from Arunachal Pradesh.
So that group came in directly from India.
And same as the group of
1000 I was talking about
before that took place in
the United States, right?
They came in, they had a plan,
they had people waiting for
them, Canadian citizens,
many of whom were Tibetan
Canadian citizens, jobs.
So that sort of thing.
That's a group organized immigration
and authorized by the government.
This is different.
These are individual people
appearing at the border
petitioning for asylum.
And so to do that,
you cannot do that at a high commission.
It's same for the United
States as for Canada,
you can't go to a US
embassy around the world
and request asylum.
You can only request
that either at the border
when you're entering, or
once you're in country,
there's a period of time which you can.
- [Attendee] And then related to that,
the argument about refusal,
is it that they are refusing
citizenship in South Asia
or are you arguing that
they're refusing the status
of being undocumented and
regulated in South Asia,
or is it a possibility
of getting citizenship?
So I'm not entirely clear,
but it's 'cause I don't know
much about the context's,
whether you are arguing
they're refusing citizenship
in South Asia, in India,
or the status of not being
documented and regulated.
- They're refusing citizenship.
So since 1959, so now we're on third,
even fourth generation of
Tibetans have lived in India
with either, again, it's not
just undocumented or under,
because some of them do have
these government of India
issued documentations
that are good only in India.
The question for me actually is,
what were they offered?
And the details of this
have never been made public
either for his holiness,
the Dalai Lama's relationships
with Nairu in the 1950s
or with the King of Nepal in the 1950s,
where Tibetans offered citizenship.
That, I don't know for
sure because, again,
I don't have access to the
agreements that were made.
The way that Tibetans
publicly and privately speak
is that, we refused it.
So it's not a protest
of being undocumented,
it's an acceptance of that.
But positing it as we
are refusing citizenship
regardless of whether or
not it's offered to us.
Again, per the Constitution of India,
many Tibetans qualify for citizenship.
However, the government of India
also doesn't recognize this.
Believe me, I have to
explain this all the time
to judges in Canada and the United States.
So it's like, "Well, look
right here in the constitution,
a Tibetan would qualify."
I'm like, I understand it says
that and it looks that way,
but that is not the practice,
which again is why ethnography
and lived experience
is as important, if not more important,
sometimes than what of a losses,
because actual experience
does not correspond here
with what the legal
documents say should happen.
- [Eda] There are two questions.
- Okay.
- [Eda] So one is that,
as we got to know about the
1951 Refugee Convention,
the question that they're asking is,
why the refugee laws came
just after World War II,
but not just after the 1940s?
And can we look at that
act as something driven?
It's a general question about
the 1951 Refugee Convention.
- I'm not sure if the questions
for the world in general
or for South Asia.
I mean, the answer for both is yes.
I mean, the formulation of
refugee laws and of UNHCR
following World War II
was an attempt to solve
what was seen as the crisis of refugees
and stateless peoples in the world
following World War II.
I feel like this is
stuff many people know.
And the agreement among countries
that every piece of territory
had to be associated
to a nation state, right?
So there couldn't be a patch of land
that somehow was
independent of some state,
and that is where international
refugee law comes from.
In South Asia, the
decision not to sign on,
again, as a collectivity,
as a group of states,
clearly was a political decision
that they have held to ever since.
So to whoever is asking,
the answer is yes.
What that means for
refugees in South Asia?
If you recall the statement that I read
from the Tibetan Policy Act
is the government of India
considers Tibetans refugees.
So per government of India
terminology, they are refugees,
but that does not align them
with UN convention refugee status,
which is then a shared series
of rights or set of rights
that are supposed to be upheld
by countries around the
world that are actionable.
This is a different type of...
- [Eda] Yeah, Estrella, go ahead.
- [Estrella] In the book,
you talk about the
journeys of Latin refugees
through Nepal and Arunachal
and their encounter
with different religions,
different cuisine,
and sort of how that
experience to move for them
was like a world expanding
experience culturally.
And like I was struck by that
when you were talking about (indistinct)
and stuff like that.
And I was wondering specifically like,
what have you observed
or what have the people you've spoken with
observed about themselves
in terms of social rules,
attitudes, behaviors, that
remained sticky for them
as it was when they lived at home,
versus after all of these years of life
living in a different place
and navigating different cultures.
and this can be in
(indistinct) like gender
or even like teaching or
socializing or whatever.
- I guess two things.
One, Tibetans are incredibly cosmopolitan.
So Tibetans live in multiple
countries around the world,
as well as the bulk of Tibetans
still to this day live inside Tibet
as part of the People's Republic of China.
And each year, more and more Tibetans
come from Tibet outside,
especially for education.
And so there's lots of movement.
This is a community that,
while for a long time was
very much only in Asia
for the last 20 years,
has become really truly
an international diaspora.
So that sense of cosmopolitanism,
whereas if we think of what
was it that enabled China,
what was one of the things anyways,
that enabled China to take over Tibet,
to just march right in and invade was,
Tibet didn't have diplomatic
relations with any countries
except for Nepal.
So, I mean, it was the opposite
of a cosmopolitan country.
It was very much
insulated, inward focused,
looking at Buddhism,
it had not yet entered
the world of modern diplomacy
in terms of building relationships
with other countries,
and so there were no countries
who then had those sort
of diplomatic obligations
to step in.
So there's that.
But in thinking specifically
about South Asia,
which is where Tibetans came into, 1959,
and really up until the year 2000,
the overwhelming majority
of Tibetan in exile
were in South Asia.
One of the big things I think
that that has been overlooked
has been a conservativism in
gender expression and roles.
So actually a shrinking of
possibilities for women,
and I think that is
something that has emerged
from coming into society dominated
by kind of Hindu and Muslim wars,
and a much more conservative
public profile for women
than what Tibetans had
experienced prior to that.
That's something I've thought about.
No one to my knowledge has
actively researched it,
but that's one thing.
What does it mean to come
into a different society
where rules for even just
like what parts of the body
need to be covered when
you appear in public,
what's considered decors or not right
for a woman to how she
comports herself in public,
things like that.
So South Asia has been very influential
on the Tibetan community.
Anyone who grew up there
can probably sing and dance
any number of Bollywood songs
going all the way back decades.
So like, there's the
influences that are beloved,
and that are charming and that are fun.
Culinary influences as well.
And then there's the ones
that fly a little bit lower
under the surface, I think,
such as this, conservativism,
not that Tibet wasn't a
conservative society earlier,
but I think it manifested
itself in new ways in exile,
and gender, I believe, is one of them.
- [Eda] One more question.
- We have one question.
- Sure.
- [Staff] John, if you
want to unmute yourself
and ask the question.
- [John] Yes.
In the 1960s, one of the
first groups of Tibetans
to leave South Asia went to Switzerland.
Do you know what happened to those people
and how much of a
Tibetan presence there is
in Switzerland today?
- I do.
They are still there.
So until very recently,
Switzerland, you're right,
had the longest standing kind
of oldest Tibetan community.
It was kind of Switzerland and the UK,
although the number of Tibetans in the UK
was also always much smaller
than the number of Switzerland.
So it's a thriving community now,
and it's now a community.
And Tibetans actually are kind
of throughout from Geneva...
All sorts of cities in Switzerland,
centered in the Zurich
area and (indistinct),
and that part of the country.
But now is a community that,
kind of like the community
in India and Nepal,
is three generations deep.
So fully, younger
generation is fully immersed
into Swiss life,
whether it's Swiss French or Swiss German,
and a very successful community as well.
So just prior to the
pandemic, I was working on,
I was going to be adding
France and Switzerland
to my study of refugee
citizenship around the world,
and I planned on spending
the summer of 2020
half in Paris and half in Zurich,
and then (indistinct).
The situation changed, but,
so I'm hoping to go back.
So very active community there,
but a community that is now truly Swiss,
as well as Tibet,
and yet maintaining active ties
to Tibetans around the world, right?
There's no Tibetan...
I can't think of any
Tibetan friend of mine
or colleague I know who
doesn't have family members
in multiple countries
around the world, right?
So my Swiss friends,
Swiss Tibetan friends,
have relatives in D.C.
and relatives in Delhi
and families still inside Tibet.
So an important country for Tibetans
because Tibetans have been residents there
since the early '60.
Again, one of those first
places outside of South Asia,
and still an active and vibrant community.
- [Attendee] Thank you.
- Yeah, you're welcome.
- [Staff] You wanna close it or...
All right.
- That's the question.
- Oh, great.
I have been thinking...
I've been thinking about
both your and Audra's concept
of refusal as sort of
historically contingent modes
of agency that are made
differential available
to different people.
And I was struck by
essentially what you said,
essentially in the global
south, in South Asia,
the refusal is available as...
Because being undocumented
and underdocumented
is a possibility of life,
whereas in the global
north where it is not,
refusal looks different.
And so then I think with
Catherine Besteman's
sort of militarized global apartheid,
and I'm wondering how the Tibetan
sort of situation and this sort
of different modes of agency
or different modes of
refusal co-articulate
with this militarized global apartheid
to also bring in your wonderful
book, "Arrested Histories,"
which deals with the CIA
history and so forth.
But, yeah.
- Oh, absolutely.
I mean, articulates it.
And I think what comes to me initially
is not from my own
research, but from Audra.
So the scholar we're
referring to, Audrey Simpson,
has a book called "Mohawk Interruptus."
And one of the things she
talks about in this book
is not just her own crossing
of the US-Canadian border,
but of the Mohawk, the Iroquois
National Lacrosse Team,
traveling to South America
and insisting on using their
Iroquois Nation passports,
and then trying to come back into.
So they received, they can
go to South America on those,
but when they tried to
come back in, right?
And what does it mean to say...
And they, of course, also
have a US or have a Canadian passport,
what does it mean to say,
I'm not going to use that one?
I think this gets into it directly.
Like, who is allowed to make what choices?
Who is allowed to refuse what?
And this is why refusal, I think,
as so many of us are articulating it
is different than resistance, right?
Resistance requires that
relationship of subjugation, right?
It unfolds in a landscape that's unequal.
Subordination is part of resistance.
You are pushing back.
Refusal is a horizontal relationship.
Like, I have a US passport,
I'm not going to use it.
I'm going to insist right on
using this other passport.
And what does it take?
This is back to that Tibetan woman
who felt the shame and the
stigma of showing up that like,
what does it take to have
that sort of sensibility
to be able to refuse publicly
when facing a security officer?
Like, what are the stakes,
what are the repercussions,
when can you make that
move and when can you not?
Because there certainly
are some situations
in which that is not an option.
And resistance might not be
either in certain states.
But I would say, absolutely
they're similar things
with deep resonance.
- [Attendee] It's helpful
because the cyclical question of agency
that keeps coming every 20, 30 years,
concepts like refusal help
us provide a topography
of different modes that is not...
Do these people have agency or don't they?
So thank you for that.
- Oh, sure.
Well, thank you all,
and thank you folks who
were watching online.
Yeah, glad you were all here.
(crowd applauding)